mais j'ai vraiment pas cette place moi
je sais plus où ranger les affaires
qu'est ce que je vais faire de ce truc
je vais me met là peut-être bon on va le
téléphone le téléphone il serait pas mal
à le bocal oui mais alors le bocal de
caramel bacio il me remette la côté d
autres bonbons ben oui mais je me
retrouve avec ça mais ça va pas du tout
du tout du tout du tout ni j'ai ouï
casimir excuse moi j'ai vraiment pas le
temps de discuter
je suis dans les problèmes de range non
non je ne sent pas bon mais excuse moi
de te déranger
comment faire ah bonjour je suis bien
embêté j'aimerais beaucoup que julie me
chante la chanson mais elle est très
occupé et je ne peux même pas lui parler
si si je l'obligent à m'écouter
elle va se mettre en colère elle ne
chantera pas d'un autre côté si je ne
lui demande pas bien ne changera jamais
c'est compliqué un homme et j'ai j'ai
une idée
ouais attendait les enfants
bon il y a des garçons là oui bon il y à
des filles aussi
parfait bien à françois oui je voudrais
que tu inventes un nouveau jeu un
nouveau jeu mais pourquoi j'en connais
des tas
non mais il faut absolument que tu en
invente un nouveau c'est très important
au boycott casimir je vais essayer un
baiser il faut que ce soit un jeu facile
un jeu facile ça c'est plus difficile
est un jeu facile c'est difficile elle
est bien bonne
bon tout va bien tout est prêt d'accord
julie oui quand julie c'est vraiment
important oui regarde par là qu'est ce
que tu vois
benj des enfants bon mais tu es genre
d'enfant
qu'est ce que tu veux dire des filles et
des garçons
voilà très bien maintenant regarde moi
oui et alors non mais attends attends 2
avec une chanson et un peu d'imagination
je vous emmène dans notre île
au pays du bonheur tranquille puisque je
comprends pas qu est ce que tu veux et
tu n'as pas compris ce qu'est en train
de chanter ta chanson voilà c'est ça bon
maintenant regard de françois de
françois qu'est-ce-qu'il 1 il invente un
nouveau jeu facile
ça y est j'ai compris pourquoi invente
un nouveau jeu facile je vois des filles
et des garçons casimir chance à chauffer
tu veux que je te sens tu vas chaud
c'est ça ça fait vraiment plaisir tous
ept
j'aime bien le mans quand tu chantes bon
et bien d'accord au casimir regarde j'ai
trouvé une place et battus voire c'est
mon idée qui a porté bonheur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de couleurs
[Musique]
avec beaucoup de douceur
je voudrais faire
très mal
givaudan et les garçons
oh
casimir chose
[Musique]
françois
nouveau jeu
mais je leur ai mieux pas si je vais me
laffont mais j'aimerais mieux peu si
j'étais à l'enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le kiosque que les poupées
on est
écoliers
couleurs série
tous
en plus
à papillons passe
une bombe
[Musique]
utile m
mais je m'en fais mieux tard si je
devais un jour
si j'étais ça longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]